[Music]  the fate of the universe lies on your  shoulders  whatever you do don't push this but cuz  that will set off the bomb immediately  and we'll all be dead  now repeat back what I just said congra  no that's the button of them kill  everyone try again  conquer mm-hmm uh-huh does anybody have  any tape out there I want to put some  tape over the death but nobody has any  tape not a single person has pain you  have an atomic bomb in your bag if  anybody's gonna have tape it's you I  have to do ever you are wasting a lot  that's a really bad sign  does anybody have any tape out there I  want to put some tape over the death but  nobody has any tape not a single part